Braddock is a town that can tell us a
lot about how America might vote in a
state that's expected to pick the next
president and there's one burning factor
where candidates stand on fracking
natural gas it is a swing issue in a
swing state Donald Trump has made clear
he wants to put oil and gas development
at the very heart of his election
campaign but when it comes to Democrats
well it's a little more complicated the
moderates in the Democratic race want
regulation you would not call for a ban
statewide on fracking or nationwide you
said stop new oil and gas drilling on
federal lands yes and I would also go
back and look at what's out there now to
determine whether or not it is safe but
Bernie Sanders is backing a ban my state
of Vermont became the first state in the
nation to ban fracking that's a risk in
struggling Union heartlands wooed by
Trump in 2016 my job is to represent the
people of Pittsburgh not the people of
Paris these coke plant workers believe
Bernie's opposition to fracking could
floor him fracking come along and it
just there are so many jobs that
provided it's just unbelievable
especially there's Pittsburgh area and
through all the unions and everything
else so it just it just put a spike in
everything yes you worried about climate
change no no don't believe in it I think
that's just a cash cow made up to bring
money and it's my belief
did you think that before Donald Trump
called it I hope yes yep there's been
five ice ages in the last four and a
half billion years there's no heavy
industry or automobiles what caused that
maybe this global warming is going to
prevent the next ice age anybody ever
think about that so we done
endorsing Democrats or going one way or
the other I'm not entirely sure yet but
it's pretty clear that the membership
here is largely backing Republicans
Braddock was home to America's first
major steel mill those glory days
evaporated replaced by the fog of
hardship how you feel depends in part on
where you sit in the climate change
debate young environmental activists
many who lean towards Bernie Sanders
know they've got their work cut out do
you think climate change is enough of an
issue to change the shape of the 2020
race I think so but that's me being
optimistic because I think that if I
think it isn't I'm just going to like
fall into a really depressive episode so
I have to tell myself that it's enough I
think it's going to be important in the
Democratic primary but beyond the
primary I would have a hard time
thinking that people would choose
between whatever the Democratic nominee
is and Trump based on climate change
they'll be thinking more about Medicare
and other issues like that we tend to
think you know because we've had
extractive industries in southwestern
Pennsylvania for so long we sometimes we
get this mindset that it's the only way
that we can make money it's the only way
that we can support our families but
it's really not clean energy jobs in
Pennsylvania are growing five times
faster than the normal employment rate
fracking involves pumping millions of
gallons of water chemicals and sand into
the earth I think fracking is complex
but I think what it is more so as a
desperation
summerleigh says it's adding to an
already overwhelming health crisis
fracking can have
terrible health impacts on communities
on their water on birth weight for kids
and then when you add that on top of a
community like ours that already has the
worst amongst the worst air quality in
the nation you know that already has
poor water quality poor air quality we
already have high rates of asthma COPD
cancer respiratory illnesses it's almost
like what more do you need to inflict on
communities like ours she successfully
campaigned on an anti fracking message
and believes African Americans suffering
here and their political power are being
overlooked people don't recognize that
black and brown and poor folks but
specifically black and brown folks are
more likely to live by an environmental
hazard but I can tell you that I've read
unapologetically on a platform that
talked about environmental justice on a
platform that talked about a moratorium
on fracking you know that talked about
prioritizing people's health cutting
subsidies to big corporations you know
we talked about good union jobs also and
one resoundingly down the road though
John Fetterman who became a face of the
Rust Belt renewal warns Democrats need
to get real in a state he calls the
Saudi Arabia of natural gas because I
fundamentally believe that Pennsylvania
is going to pick the next president
you'd want to err on the side of of
pragmatic reality from a transition
towards renewable energy and
independence from fossil fuels as
opposed to an abrupt let's turn off the
switch
in Pennsylvania's post-industrial
pockets natural gas extraction has been
a source of economic revival betting
against it is bold and brave
it may also color this race Cordelia
Lynch Sky News Braddock Pennsylvania